making you a big puts it at risk to
suffer from all these downsides bigger
appaluse acquisitions and bigger apps
also get uninstalled to free up space
I'm sure you already know that and
you've probably just considered it a
trade-off do you add new features and
support more device configurations but
lose installs and drive more and
installs we don't want you to have to
worry about these trade-offs the app
bundle is the official Android app
publishing format apps that have already
adopted the bundle are seeing an average
size saving of 35% that's compared to a
universal apk and that's quite a lot
all these developers around the world
have switched and have seen fantastic
size savings duolingo for example so are
56% size saving compared to a universal
apk and it's really hard to get such big
savings from incremental optimizations
we've added a new Android platform
optimization to the app bundle called
uncompressed native libraries his
artwork on Android Ellen below native
libraries have to be uncompressed from
the apk before the platform can use them
meaning the user ends up with two copies
of the library after Android em the
platform can read the library directly
from the apk if it's left uncompressed
thus saving a copy on the device to do
it yourself you will need to need to
upload two versions of your app and
create multi apk for pre and post M if
you're using the app bundle you just
give us your libraries and we and we
create the required flavor for pre and
post M and serve the right appliquéd to
the right user dynamic features can be
installed on demand when user requests
them or you can choose to defer
installing them to a later time when the
app goes to the background for pre L
devices which don't support on demand
features we can fuse the modules into
the main app so they delivered at
install time all of these use cases are
supported in production today we
millions of users benefiting already now
that we've created our on-demand modules
let's write the code to download them in
order to interact with the Play Store to
request these on-demand modules we have
to use the split install API which is
part of the play core library this is a
Java client library that communicates
with the Play Store via IPC under studio
and Gradle are not the only ways that
you can build bundles today because the
format and bundle tool are open-source
others are already adopting them for
example we're excited to share that
games using unity can now boy it build
Android app bundles to unity added
support in the 20 18 point 3 beta
release and you can join the beta
program now
[Music]